here's the first story we have from the
post to Millennial breaking and you know
the post-millennial prominent
conservatives locked out of Twitter
after reporting on trans day of
Vengeance they have this image here it
says remove tweet violating our rules
against violent speech you may not share
abusive content harass someone or
encourage other people to do so this is
a post from the post-millennial on
Twitter that said radical trans
activists and a DC antifa Group are
organizing a trans day of Vengeance
protest and they've blurred the day and
the location because Twitter is cracking
down now I saw initial reporting that
Marjorie Taylor green had been suspended
for calling it out and the initial
assumption was that people were who were
reporting on this and criticizing it
were getting suspended they were but
what Twitter claims to have been trying
to do I think I might have the Tweet uh
here
this is Ella Irwin responding to Ian
miles Chong saying uh in Miles Chong
tweets Twitter is now cracking down on
those who promote the trans day of
Vengeance poster which mostly comprises
of trans militants who are calling for a
day of mass violence do not share the
poster or you could be caught up in the
bands to prevent Mass violence from
happening Ella Irwin responds correct
we had to automatically sweep our
platform and remove more than 5 000
tweets and retweets of this poster we do
not support tweets that incite violence
irrespective of who post them Vengeance
does not imply peaceful protest
organizing a supportive peaceful protest
is okay
this is fascinating this is absolutely
fascinating because for one we're still
seeing a problem of contextless
censorship you know criticizing this is
not same as promoting it but the
automated censorship can't track that
but more importantly
when I went on Rogan's show all those
years ago with Dorsey and vegetate I
specifically highlighted leftist
violence incitement events was being
allowed on the platform meanwhile people
on the right were being banned now
Twitter is actually cracking down and
removing left-wing calls for extreme
violence I wonder if this is an
inflection point yeah it's really
interesting fascinating to see how this
has evolved and and who's to credit for
it you know Elon Musk I guess or some of
the new teams that are in there trying
to crack down but it's interesting
because we see people like MTG
um Andy no they're hitting them but only
because they put it out there to
highlight it that this is improper to
call for Trans Vengeance and violence
like this which is you should have a
right to be able to call it out and say
this isn't proper this is dangerous it
doesn't you know belong here in you know
in society but that then they try to go
back and say no no no no no we just
don't want anything suggesting violence
not even anyone criticizing the people
who are calling for violence I'm not mad
at Twitter about this one though I they
corrected it yeah they've restored the
accounts they did an automatic sweep I
I'm actually curious Ian's perspective
because you you moderated for mines yeah
so I'm wondering I mean if you're
watching far left extremists or foreign
extremists for that matter
thousands of accounts promoting a day of
mass violence what do you do I think
they did the right thing too because
it's like if someone posts child
pornography on Twitter and then other
people like retweeting it and saying
look how gross this is you're still
complicit in proliferating child porn at
that point so I understand what they did
they had to they had to rip out the
roots and if you were hanging on the
tree branches you're gonna fall down
when that tree comes out well they did
the right thing by reinstating the
accounts right I agree it's a little
it's a little bit more than I would say
I'd say you should be allowed to report
on it you should be as a reporter
allowed to share this and say look what
they're calling for you need to know
this because if you live in DC I think
it's very important you see who and what
uh who's sharing it and what's being
shared it's a constant struggle in the
administrationship of social medias how
do you report on images and imagery that
violates
the terms because you can't show it
you're violating the terms if you show
them you can but you're violating the
terms to show it
um you can blur it out but they're not
really showing it so no one knows what
you're reporting on right but then is
that censorship it's definitely a form
of censorship well not that's the
quandary not all censorship is bad
okay yeah uh if someone posts like like
Ian mentioned child porn you want
sensors to catch that and get rid of it
and then refer to the police yeah well
that's a crime right exactly and so the
problem is what we often end up seeing
from these big social platforms is
protection for left-wing extremist
ideology
and then they ban a conservative saying
learn to code now my attitude here is
okay well it sucks that Andy Marjorie
TPM and others got suspended Twitter did
reinstate it but my view is if all of
these far left extremists are calling
for and what is it it's this Saturday
they are calling for a weekend Mass
violent wave considering what just
happened the other day with that trans
Mass shooter yeah Twitter's like we
gotta get this off the platform now so
it's a challenge of
if you're reporting on it you shouldn't
get censored for reporting on it but if
you get caught up in a mass sweep to
eliminate extremism and then get
reinstated
it's it's unfortunate I'm not going to
cry about it it's kind of like a
reporter standing on the side of the
street while there's a riot and they're
recording the cops are like get out of
here and they grab the reporter with
everyone else they arrest the reporter
then they let him go like that's
actually a fair point like drug sweeps
when people get pulled up for uh in
police raids and then some people are
there who aren't actually there legally
committing any crimes and then hopefully
if done properly they're released upon
finding out that they're not actually
guilty of anything whether that's
possession of some type of substance or
a weapon or anything like that so it
feels more like something like that also
I did want to ask is this connected
directly to the the image that they're
posting or is it keyword search with uh
hashtags I think it's the image okay and
I but I will stress this as much as look
I don't want anybody who's calling this
out and criticizing it to get suspended
this is suspension should not be the
image it should be the call for it for
the action and so Marjorie Taylor green
has two tweets we can see right here the
Tweet violated the Twitter rules they're
both removed they shouldn't be and it
looks like she got a third one that was
removed as well four it looks like there
are four tweets that have been removed
probably because she was saying hey this
is bad they should be restored you
should be allowed to share the image
it's then call for violence well it's
like you she's trying to call out
something that is a call for violence
that can be but you know potential like
criminal conduct and that also in my
opinion presents an issue and a real
threat to Public Safety so when you
think about it I would want to know if
I'm living in that area that there's
going to be this trans Vengeance
situation call for violence no offense
as a public safety issue if I'm going
down the street if I'm going somewhere I
want to know what's actually going on
and be alerted to it in my community
that's the other problem I have it just
with my background and understanding how
these things happen someone could be
walking into that they don't know what's
going on I would want to be it's almost
like a virtual or social media community
policing where their people are putting
it out there hey FYI look out for this
this is what's going to happen in the
neighborhood you should be aware of
what's happening in your community I
don't want to have like you know a mask
over my eyes cover my eyes cover my ears
and not know what's going on around me I
actually do want to be informed so
there's that as well with getting the
message out I know you have to think
about that you're a prosecutor yes how
would you handle people I mean there's
thousands of people posting this call
for violence I mean what would you do
yeah I mean I think it's a real problem
the call for violence but since it's
actually an event that is going to take
place then you also I believe have a
responsibility to let people know and to
be aware of it and then if you're a
prosecutor in law enforcement Etc you
want to try to control the situation
mitigate the damage the threat to Public
Safety the mitigate the threat of
personal injury or harm to people of
Riots of creating an unsafe situation
which we have seen happen over and over
again with the call for situations like
this whether it's Ferguson or you know
with the hands up don't shoot which then
turned out to not have you know happened
but they said what was important to call
this out I'm telling you it goes on from
here and there and then this is the same
situation but people want to be a little
bit more sensitive to it because it
involves you know trans issues like no I
don't care who you are how you identify
who you sleep with you know you don't
have a right to commit violence that
hinders the community and causes harm to
other human beings that is not a right
that you have so here's the challenge
the poster doesn't explicitly call for
violence it calls for vengeance right
well it's got enough buzzwords for
people to figure it out do you think you
could or should prosecute someone for
creating this and calling for this and
posting on the internet no but that's
criminal versus civilly so it put it
this way if it's something where there's
like a threat of violence we call them
terrorist threats but that's just the
the name on the penal code for a lot of
this which is if you threaten the life
of somebody and say you know I'm gonna
do this or that'll cause you know harm
to someone
um and you threaten them you're not
allowed to do that okay and that can
rise to the level of a felony but so but
this will say well this is just you know
a poster calling for people to meet
peacefully that's how they'll they'll
sugar coated however the people behind
it if ultimately that event takes place
and someone does get injured or harmed
then you're looking at a civil Forum
where someone can come in and Sue the
people who through the event Etc which
by the way we saw with January 6 right
so okay how did that start who's through
it people went who was injured lawsuits
ensued and it's in the courts a lot of
it right now
even using language like Vengeance it's
isn't that just neo-marx's Behavior
right to just use vague language which
they can manipulate at any time that
they want to mean whatever they want
because it's vague and it doesn't
actually have any type of implement uh
like implication to it but we know what
it means well we know what it means
because there's rifles on the picture
next to the word Vengeance I mean even
that like but that would come up in
court and it's the image that we're
talking about especially the image just
following what happened in Nashville
yeah with these these these poor
children and these faculty members yeah
there is a clear understanding of what
that poster means there's context
there's context out in the news in the
media socially Etc so people put it
together well here's the crazy thing is
that trans advocacy groups are still
pushing they're saying Get Ready they're
telling people to take up guns and
prepare for a fight after everything
that just happened it's so insane to me
that you would think that in because in
order to stop the government from
harming children you're going to hurt
children like that's what this girl did
yes there it is yeah she she shot up six
six people three kids three nine year
olds because she was afraid that the
government was I don't know I don't know
her intentions actually I've seen text
of she said she was suicidal could be
fake text I don't know I don't know how
many hormones and drugs dming your
friend and Etc yeah but that you think
that killing people is gonna solve is
gonna protect you from the government
killing people it doesn't that's that's
that's not what they're saying though
there this is an ideological battle they
they are looking at they look at the
rhetoric around Christians and what they
think of Christians and it's and it's
kind of clear why this person did this
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time